right time for loss region with a big
pair of bollocks and a fiery temper to
take on Hardeep Singh Kohli hey do very
well sir how are you are you ready very
ready for you nervous and you nervous
I'm excited and listen I do this a lot
it's cock-a-leekie on the menu a chicken
and leek Scottish classic now Hardy's
making a soup that cost less than a
fiver to make so I'm not either the same
slightly cheaper but more delicious
let's do a long time since I met a [ __ ]
leaking soup
oh he's coming out early oh oh I think I
can hear it did you hear that
what are you doing the other with all
these leagues well I'm trying to go for
a layer of flavor so you're roasting
leeks sweating leeks and I'm also gonna
add some pan-fried leeks at the end and
also some more will go in just before
the end so they'll be like four layers
of leeks going on in the dish leeks four
ways hold on a minute
what do you come over here there's a
fifth place is perfect fifth thing we
can do the leaf do you worry you worried
Ramsey because a food knowledge check
good luck
check [ __ ] swear okay okay chickens
in the oven roasting just bone out roast
it on the skin this is our bacon what I
want to do is just find that bake off
with some color gets really nicely
crispy
crushed garlic chopped potato chopped
carrot and really start to roast those
leagues is that a euphemism Gordon
roasting you lean and stop thinking
about my [ __ ] and comment on helpers
Gordon ah now I'm actually having
something up I've certainly got
what are you doing this fascination
vanilla my chicken thighs are cooking
nicer thank you need another five or six
minutes and I just roasted some leeks
and with them because I genuinely do
believe in this idea of kind of flavors
echoing around the dish if you can if
you can make it happen so cooking the
leeks different ways just brings out
different components of their their
flavor are you [ __ ] you using string
it's sooo what you're using string for
I'm making a bouquet garni yeah Raymond
Blanc told me you do that Ray Blanc that
he's actually born in Shellington
chicken's burning back out now I think
that's not burning love that caramelized
you see oh [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry baby I'm
[ __ ] real yeah baby
we've got charisma yes you've got charm
you're very good at cooking you're from
Glasgow there's only one thing missing
oh god you know that is your turbine
because shall we
are you ready are you ready for the
hardy turbine along back off back off
yeah because you know you're gonna look
great however we tie it think about this
is pet filo pastry this is incredible
don't think beyond food it's a communist
tug of war that's extraordinary
it's like making bizarre tegra telly
bite on that I don't let go by Tommy
honestly I'm not bending over that's
what his mouth says as I say different
okay it's might hurt your hair Weaver
look Nora that's me a lot of money that
hair don't [ __ ] it up right so I'll have
a chicken tikka to Papa Dom's and apply
the Cobra beer [ __ ] off sir buh dum